[Music]
hi guys I'm avi and I love one-liner
jokes here's one that I came up with I
know I should love myself before I love
anyone else but me and myself for seeing
other people right now I thought I'd
challenged my friends to come up with
one-liners in 24 hours I feel like I can
tell if something's funny but I'm
personally not funny I don't think
anyone thinks
Kame he's hilarious I think I can be
funny when I'm not supposed to be funny
but if somebody tells me to ask me to
tell a joke or I'm supposed to make
people laugh bandages all what collapses
and I am I fail I'm hoping that like
right one funny joke and just remember
that for the rest of my life today there
has to be a science to this hi I'm dr.
solitaire though I'm a linguist and I
specialize in the linguistics of humor
there is something called the principle
of cooperation and basically the idea is
that when you communicate you're
following some rules all jokes have to
violate in some aspect the principle of
cooperation take for example the job by
Demetri Martin I think the worst time to
have a heart attack is during a game of
charades when you reach the word charade
you realize that in fact the speaker
wasn't cooperating when you get that you
get one of the basic foundations of you
to help kanan Fernando I brought in a
stand-up comedy teacher okay there is no
way to do it don't try to be funny try
to be honest have it come from some
place in you
alright guys that's our class wait is
this the whole lesson wait what this is
so much harder than I thought it'd be I
have one and a half jokes so I'm about
to test the just for the very first time
on one I used to be embarrassed about
how my boyfriend and I met but then I
realized but I realize some people get
used to I'm the one I supposed to be
laughing they're like I can't believe
I'm the person that starts laughing
before I can finish a joke I was trying
to write these jokes I needed five I can
only come up with one and a half okay
guys so just please be gentle I have
long joke okay so you know how I'm like
a Mexican immigrant right something
that's really been bugging me for a
while as a Donald Trump was saying that
we are rapists and we are criminals and
we're here to steal people's jobs the
job he probably thinks we're getting is
joining the Republican Party and running
for Congress get it okay I didn't get it
until the last second I was like oh
verbal validation from Asian parents is
like being constipated it takes less
when tears just to get a little bit out
I used to be embarrassed to say my
boyfriend and I met online but hey
sometimes you get furniture off
Craigslist sometimes you get a boyfriend
[Music]
so I finished all the one-liners and
told all the people I got a lot of just
silent stares and confusion but you know
it's okay not everyone can do what I did
in the day I think if anything just made
me understand how difficult it is to
consciously be funny even though I got a
lot of awkward silences I almost didn't
care because I was just proud that I was
able to go through with it and perform
[Music]